i love my wife i really do i've been
with my wife a long time
and she's great she's a gentile from
tennessee
but she's american indian that's what
turns me on about it like i look at him
like a ancestors shot bow and
arrows and
hunted people she's got like a up
lift and a twisted ear she's not all you
know
she don't rain dance and then she can't
hear me walk up behind this she's not
she's not a real indian a real indian
you can't tiptoe behind no turn
around
i love my wife my wife and i have a good
time except for a couple months ago let
me tell you when i peed the bed right
when you pee the bed they cannot
handle that women will put up with
anything else
they really will my wife is a
saint what she puts up with
but pee in the bed she was pale
for a week do you understand
it's amazing i had like surgery done and
they gave me like
i don't know what the happened and
you know you just wake up one night you
peed the bedding
and you run to the bathroom and you
finish peeing whatever you got and you
think about what the happened
whenever you peed a bed
you always realize what the
happened what made me pee the
bed
and that's why i never make fun of
people peter bet because it's a p dream
a p dream is the best dream
you'll ever have
in your life because it has a beginning
a middle and an end okay
and then it goes off like a bad
movie it just goes off and
but it really does that's the pi that's
how you pee nothing just you don't go to
bed you can drink a gallon of water you
won't be
it's a p dream all right you're walking
down the streets of dc
right you're headed to a nationals game
whatever the you do in your spare
time
you know you see a bag full of money
you're a christian right you know you're
not gonna take the whole bag
i'll take a couple bundles i'll buy a
piano for the church nobody'll know
nothing right but then you go it
i'm taking a whole bag you know what the
the church done and you pick
it up and as soon as you pick it up you
hear helicopters and sirens and
you
you run even though you're a decent
person you start running right you hear
it
and you throw the money in like
a dumpster and then you go to see what
the address is at that point
specifically
your mind will wake you up and say
wake up you gotta pee and you'll go
oh my god okay our people hold on let me
go back to the dream
and see where i hit the money
right
but then you go back to that dream and
there's no money
there's no building there's no national
game this dick
it's a cow and a fence there's
nothing
you see like i got lied to again
all right i guess i'll go pee but in the
middle of that another vision comes like
this other dream
and it's like this hot woman waking you
up get up get up
be like who are you and they're like
come with me
you're like okay but i gotta pee first
right
when you get up she's got no legs she's
floating like a bubble guppy right but
but she's banging she's got a
big dance and a bush she's just floating
up in here
and you start floating with her you
ain't got no legs either
are you like just hold on not there let
me go to the bathroom first
you turn the light on the bathroom and
it's a p dream is phenomenal because
it's
it's like going to church it's like you
have like that mood like that somber or
organ music when you walk into church
you know
that smell you know you feel jesus and
i mean it's just warmth and you go and
then
and you go to take your dick out but
it's a dream it's
huge right and it just keeps coming
and coming and coming and she's looking
at you smiling you're looking at her
smiling
it's all over after i pee for you
and all of a sudden as you start peeing
oh my god
jesus is touching you you're like oh my
god this is great
in the middle of all this you actually
pee in the bed that's what
you're doing
you're like ah and you get up and
there's no woman there's no naked
women
that's a pedro and you're left
there with a stain on your bed
no answers
so women can't judge us my wife had blew
her mind listen
my wife goes to bed at 10 15 and she
don't move a muscle
until 6 30 6 15 okay not a muscle
she don't get up to pee she don't ask me
nothing i can have a party out there
this night i come home from comedy
and i go out to get rolling papers and
come back at three and she still don't
hear me he didn't hear me when
they get rolling papers in the sandwich
no i didn't
the night i peed on the way back i could
see her eyes blinking right in the bed
so i'm coming around i'm coming back to
assess the damage right just to see what
what happened right i pulled the blanket
up and i'm looking and right away she's
like what's going on i go not nothing
go back to bed all right she's like i
know something's going on
i peed the bed she got right up where i
go not my side not your side all right
that's why there's a body pillow for
just go back to bed that's got nothing
to do with you
she goes what do you mean this guy's
gonna do with me we have to change the
sheets we don't have to do dick do you
understand me
i got insomnia if we change the
sheets that means they're gonna go on
the balcony smoke pot
come in eat something watch lawn all
jerk enforcement
and for what for one hour
that
that i'm going back to bed
and she's like you're not gonna change
it she's no i'm gonna put a towel
on that
and put my sleep happiness right back on
and press go and i'm going right back to
nappy noodleville
and that was it it i slept on that
piece staying all night
like a doctor i didn't even feel it
best night of sleep i ever had
i woke up she's like what the is
wrong with you
you're a grown goddamn man
like say one more word i'll tell
you what i'll pee in that bed every
goddamn night
the inside of that mattress will look
like the inside of a tree
there'll be circles all the way around